hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
there is a sure and not completely
worked out but very important discussion
of what we would call the philosophy of
action in Aristotle's Nicomachean ethics
blocks it that deals with the relations
between the intellectual the the
desirous or the effective and human
action if you're really interested in
this another place that you can go to to
see a similar treatment with a little
bit more discussion of how it connects
with other things would be air settles
de anima or on the soul and also the
rhetoric can be can be useful in looking
at these matters
that said the nipa making an ethics
discussion of it is fairly
self-contained
and we're going to look at that yes sort
of the prime example so Aristotle asks
at one point which of these which of
these prime contenders as he says the
carrillo type is right produces actions
and word there for actions is proxies
meaning distinctively human actions he's
going to exclude the realm of mere
stimulus-response that he thinks that a
lot of animal action is engaged with
which of these
whose actions and their body produces
what we can call practical truth if
you're if you're not understanding what
practical truth means you can take a
look at the video specifically on truth
in thought or in theory and an action
that we've done so he proposes three
contenders at this point and one of
these is uses two different terms here
that are often synonymous for Aristotle
intellect or thought don't mix this up
by the way with the the virtue the
intellectual virtue that we sometimes
translated as intellect he's not talking
about that here as news but rather the
sort of capacity that we have for for
intellection in general news or vietnam
the annoy has a word coming from news
yeah so they're really you know I think
are thinking about things those are that
are thinking about things that produces
our actions and our you know what we
have of practical truth or is it
something else
another possibility designer or aspect
if 'ti the greek term for that is or
racist
aristotle actually distinguishes several
kinds of racists there is you know for
example the the physical desires that we
feel or for pleasures of also for mental
pleasures
there is the the sumos which you know
compasses things like anger the rival
wrists emotions and then there is boo
boo yeah well that was just the will or
wish which were incest towards towards
ends all the other forms of activity
tend to orient just towards ends as well
not always the best ends and then
finally we have per session i stasis and
my stasis covers a lot of ground we tend
to think of just our senses like sight
and touch those are particulars of my
stasis but the aristotle uses this term
a stasis in two other very important
ways in the makeup
ethics and in other words Aristotle will
say that we have my stasis or perception
of particulars which means not just that
we sense them but that we grasp them as
what they are as individual things as
having certain properties and qualities
and heaven you might say a certain kind
of you know importance or lack of
importance relevance would be another
way to talk about it when we're talking
about ethics a lot of ethics boils down
to what we do in particular contexts in
individual situations and so I stasis is
important for that my stasis also is
involved in the perception of what we
come moral qualities we perceive things
as good or bad just and unjust
pleasurable or painful right or wrong
Noble or base you know useful or or
harmful we also infer things about them
but we here are some things we have a
more direct way of connecting with with
things in the world that way so that
could be a motivator that could produce
actions possibly all three of these are
options that a person Aristotle thinks
might take he will say that I stasis
doesn't by itself produce any actions
why not well because the actions that it
does tend to produce or to stimulus
response they're not praxis they're not
distinctively human actions and so he's
not going to talk about it much at that
point anymore
so it really comes down to intellect or
activity and so when there's little now
who's going to turn to discussing
something else he's bringing another
thing into the the situation that is Pro
a racist the words we translate by
choice moral choice deliberative choice
the video specifically on that as well
Aristotle says that the cause of human
actions is choice so we need to look at
how choice works now keep in mind they
Aristotle says that choice is a subclass
of the voluntary the things that people
willingly do right so it's not
everything that we consider in action
you know for example if I sneeze that's
not a voluntary action although I
suppose my takes novice but they can
make myself sneeze that in a certain
respect it is a voluntary action
Aristotle is interested in what clauses
choice he says that choice itself is a
cause for a actions not in the sense of
final causality of being the end the the
ultimate goal that's being yeah but the
efficient clause that which gets the
ball rolling that which pushes it this
way rather than that way that which for
choice says this rather than this so
what causes choice then
Aristotle says that quat that choice is
caused by three things that's caused by
desire or axis caused by reason or
reasoning logos which is a matter of
news or via doing right and by the end
that's intended the who Annika doesn't
use them or tell us they're just says
that on account of which that's what who
Hanaka really means that the reason why
I am doing this right so all three of
these go into that Aristotle then
observes thought never moves anything by
itself so thought can play an important
role but thought itself is not the
originator for action it doesn't produce
choice by itself instead he says it's
only thought that's directed to an end
dealing with things of action that can
make things happen that way itself
doesn't do anything thought connected
together with other other matters other
concerns given a wider scope you might
say that's what I actually can lead to
now desire or a Raxus f activity is
concerned with the end desire a dozen of
us so in certain senses I don't want to
say that desire is actually more
foundational than thought because
they're actually going hand in hand with
each other in human agents but designer
cannot be left out of the picture we
cannot have a purely intellectual list
as we say account of human motivation
action and ethics now that we want to
understand what Aristotle is saying here
so you know another thing to point out
to here is that Aristotle tells us a few
other things about choice that are
relevant
he says choice may be called either
thought related to desire or desire
related to thought not I'm not the best
translation there or acted coach noose
or xst annuity king
another way of thinking about this is
thought our choice is where this
modifies this and this modifies this or
where the two of them actually come
together either you know in harmonious
integration or perhaps jarring with each
other thought thought choice is the
juncture where that happens for human
beings that some choice produces action
which of these produces actions and
practical truth it's not an exclusive
thing we're only one of them does it as
a matter of fact all three of them
figure in there these two have a more
basic role Aristotle say but I stasis
itself provides some of the basic
building blocks or information that's
that's needed and when people are
engaging in actions which can be
measured in terms of practical truth
right not only with the principle being
correct but the desire being correct
seems like activity or desire really
plays an absolutely central role in
Aristotle's theory of action